how did this mom end up here doctors
found these new phones I'm tearing these
up with my teeth like an old-school
cartoon gonna go honey Mitch does your
daughter's okay I'm ready you look
beautiful I used to hold that girl in
the palm of my hand he was becoming a
woman you're gonna have to deal with
that thanks dad why are you here you
think I'm gonna miss the most important
that of you young hey there's my
graduation graduation is for losers
tonight is the first night of our adult
lives I want to go to prom gonna lose my
goddamn virginity prom night it's kind
of perfect time in Julie left her laptop
open because just in our kids all emojis
have a secret meaning Oh eggplants are
dicks this is some kind of a dick
related agreement are not thinking
things through I may stop them I'm in
I'm fully planning on having sex tonight
wherever the night takes us the night's
gonna take us there wherever the wind
sails our ships your ship is going into
my Harbor
[Music]
there diddly wwvv d what would Vin
Diesel do Hey fasten the Furious is
completely unrealistic it's not a
documentary I get that
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about struggling contests bring it
not that kind of chugging
[Music]
you
you